but first up he is the mayor of New
Orleans his new book is in the shadow of
statues a white southerner confronts
history Mitch Landrieu
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to sunny Los Angeles I hear
you're running for president I am not
very clever very clever you're not
running a Sherman s it's about time we
had a mayor have we ever had a mayor
never never never but mayor's are the
ones who were taking care of stuff in
this country right are the ones who
actually have to respond because first
of all people live in cities that's
right eighty-five percent of people in
America live in cities is that right
yeah and that's something it actually
mayors you know one of the things that
all of the mayors of America doing non
ideologically based they're practical
people they get things done because they
see well this is why because they're in
the carpool line they're in the grocery
store right the cleaners and if you do
something wrong somebody pops you and if
you make a decision it hits the ground
the next day and the most innovative
things in the country are happening in
cities right now and it's just very
exciting it's a good time to be them we
got a great crop of Mayors across
America as we speak yeah our one here
wants to be president he sure does he's
got a guy oh I think he's got a shot so
you're supporting him I may be and then
maybe not I'm gonna keep to also have a
great senator who's running yeah I think
the Democrats have an actual good bench
I think that there will be about a
hundred and fifty people who decide yes
to try to do yes because well because a
lot of them perceive the current
president is something of a buffoon well
I think they're right so yeah I think
that I think the country feels I mean
right now obviously the president thinks
that governing in chaos is a great
strategy right I don't think the rest of
America thinks that it's a great stress
right and it's interesting because when
you say
85% of people live in cities and we are
of course it will be a very divided
country and one of the ways we're
divided is City Mouse versus country
Mouse and it does seem like Donald Trump
is never on the side of the city mouse
well I'm always with the country people
that's one way to look just weird cuz
he's from New York exactly that's one
way to look at it but the truth is for
people even that live in cities a lot of
people that don't live in cities work in
them everyday and a lot of people in the
cities depend on what people in the
rural areas produce and the people in
the rural areas depend on jobs in the
city so on the ground every day if
people don't notice this that we're
actually amongst each other and living
in peace and harmony and actually doing
a good job when we talk about President
Trump we are divided yeah what what what
now he's going after sanctuary cities
correct what is New Orleans status there
what is your position on well
interestingly enough sanctuary cities
was it was it was a term coined by the
church don't jump out of your seat
you know to give because I understand we
can talk about that later okay
but to give comfort to that to those
that way it needed need of aid and
afflicted President Trump has now turned
it into a weapon that follows his theory
that all Mexicans are rapists is that
when cities are open and welcoming
places somehow they're harboring
criminals which could not be anything
further from the truth so man's across
America and police chiefs have tried to
communicate to the Attorney General to
the president actually they have it
backwards
see when a police officer shows up at a
rape victims house and the first thing
they ask them not is not how are you but
like what is your immigration status
generally what happens is the rapist
goes free and so what mayor's across
America saying which is that our number
one priority is to protect people it
respective of the immigration status and
so what we need to do is we have to
fight criminals where they are and not
get confused that because people are not
from here that they might be more prone
to crime than anywhere else and of
course
[Applause]
[Music]
it follows right into the entire gun
violence issue that we're having in
America which is catastrophic for us all
and mayor's in America saying we know
how to protect the streets of America we
need police officers that are properly
trained we need police officers on the
st. community policing bar they need are
pretty surfacers properly trained
because we know that we need we need
police officers do our problem I know
and I'm asking if they are because we
thought we saw in Sacramento here yeah
that was an honorable episode a terrible
episode that we've seen many times
before and I just I just want to know
what you think about is the approach of
the police correct to begin with because
it seems like this emptying the whole
clip 20 shots into somebody who you're
not sure of what they did what they have
is crazy right and I've never heard I'm
not saying every policeman would do that
but I've never heard a policeman say
anything but I defend my fellow of not
doing that it seems to me at best this
is a horrible way to train police to do
their job that's love let me put it in
context for you because the city of New
Orleans mas City on the first day that I
came into office invited the Justice
Department to come in and we are
operating under one of the most intense
consent decrees to hire the right people
supervising the right way train them the
correct way and actually begin to work
with them on appropriate use of force
everybody knows we don't have to say
this most police officers are really
good folks are trying to do the right
thing there are police officers that
have been poorly hired and poorly
trained and we're retraining our police
departments as we speak so for example
in New Orleans now everyone about police
officers has a body camera on them when
there is a police involved shooting as
soon as that happens the scene gets shut
down we have what's called an
Independent Police monitor that goes out
to the scene we have a team of
investigators with the FBI embedded we
have now the practice of releasing the
tapes early so now everything is on tape
and if it is a shoot that is that is in
excessive force the police officer is I
guess a mess any more basic question
should it seems like the police have
this idea in their head that it should
be a completely no risk operation and we
know it is a job with risk by the way
they do keep statistics on this but if
policeman is the 14th ranked risky job
in America it's not the most risky well
we have had episode they seem to have
this idea that if if I feel my life is
through
and in any way I have the right to just
take you out like this guy was a thief
I don't think he deserved it most most
police chiefs in America will tell you
that that is wrong and that now we're
training police officers not to do that
to be discerning to be very thoughtful
we have had a lot of episodes where
police officers have been killed as well
and so it's a really tough balance but
in New Orleans I think you're doing in
Los Angeles there are a number of other
cities that I can't remember that under
consent decree where we're retraining
our officers to make sure that they
understand exactly when force is
necessary and when it's not and now
there are consequences to that and so
they're getting better we have a long
way to go the issue in Sacramento will
play itself out we will investigate that
find out what the circumstances are and
hopefully they'll make the right
determination about it all right so
let's talk about guns now yeah because
that's certainly I mean when you're a
policeman in this country you have to
figure that into the equation be worried
about it every day
right and tomorrow is the big March yeah
that came out of the parkland shooting
where you know I've been critical of
Democrats we're always starting the
argument with well I must I'm a big
supporter of the Second Amendment
well I'll end it there you are let me
articulate it for you further because
I'm from the south all right
first of all I'm a lawyer I believe in
the Constitution written throughout the
Constitution is a tension between giving
people's rights but we always forget
that there's always a responsibility
that attaches to that and you can be for
the Second Amendment in other words you
can acknowledge an individual's right to
own a gun to hunt and to protect
themselves but you can also be in favor
of thoughtful responsible gun ownership
look I'll give you a phrase that I think
everybody in America has got to agree
with not every American needs any kind
of gun at any time to do whatever they
want and so as a consequence
[Applause]
so as a consequence it's not it's not a
good run on that it's I could if you
were running hours but I'm not you is so
this it is not unreasonable and it's not
an unreasonable restriction on the
Second Amendment right to have universal
background checks bart to outlaw weapons
of war or to have waiting periods oughta
outlaw bomb stocks that's not
unreasonable as a matter of fact the NRA
used to kind of hang around that area
now they've gone to the extreme but let
me just give you a number this will
shock you but it's true you can test it
since 1980 less than 38 years in this
country six hundred and thirty thousand
American citizens have been killed on
the streets of America on the streets on
the streets of America that does include
no it does as well but that's in homes
so that so with gun violence that's more
that that's more people than soldiers
that have been killed in all the Wars of
the 20th century so when people say
something really simple that they want
you to accept like guns don't kill
people you just have to stop there and
say well no actually they do they were
they were created to kill and sometimes
they kill animals sometimes they kill
people and then you can say well if we
can't agree on that we could agree on
this that people actually use guns to
kill people that's true but you can't
say the guns don't kill and I think
reasonable gun restrictions make a lot
of sense and I think if you pull it if
Congress really cared about this most of
the people America believed in people
having a right to own gun but demand
responsible gun ownership and it seems
to me that we can get there and these
kids are going to demonstrate to us once
again what we adults ought to be
thinking about as we go forward okay
[Applause]
your book is about taking down the
statutes the Confederate statues in your
city I know you took a lot of heat from
certain factions did what has been the
upshot and and if if say say a mayor did
that and was running for president let's
just say not you I'm so pathetic oh yeah
asking for a friend of course
how would that issue do you think play
out well considering what you do the
book the book is it uses the prism of
the statutes which it's really about
race in America right and it's pretty
simple we need to stop judging people
based on their race creed color religion
nation of origin and do what Americans
always do or what's supposed to do
aspirationally is judge people based on
their behavior see that's a really
simple idea and we haven't done that and
we in the book also talks about the
speech that I gave this called the truth
which is like quit saying that the Civil
War was not about slavery or quit saying
that the Civil War was some kind of
noble cause you see it wasn't the Civil
War was fought to destroy the United
States of America and not to put it back
together it was fought over the cause of
slavery and for some reason we have a
difficult time dealing with that issue
so when somebody says something like I
want to make America great again
it's the comma again that causes a
problem for people and if you listen to
African Americans 60% of which run the
city of New Orleans
they say that again thing really bothers
me see that's a dog whistle about where
we want to go back to when do we want to
go back to it where were you back in
1950 and how was it for you yeah wasn't
great for everybody right and so that
notion of racial reconciliation is
critically important but essentially it
spans across the issue of immigration
guns and violence I mean everything that
you talk about who lives in cities and
who doesn't let's not go to the herb in
the center can you hear it yes okay good
you heard the IRS we've been here and so
the issue was to confront the issue of
race in America because we are a nation
that believes that everybody ought to
have a shot alright I think you ought to
have a shot
I think it'd make a fantastic
non-candidate but you do what you want
to do Mayor Mitch Landrieu Thank You mr.
mayor